every afternoon Yashoda quedar gets
ready to leave a home in the village of
family she's joined by her neighbors
dressed in identical saris they head to
a nearby school designed exclusively for
women like themselves everyone here is
above the age of 50 and illiterate son
are pushing 80 the shoulder isn't sure
exactly how old she is she guesses about
55 she's excited and nervous about
learning to write for the first time in
her life I'm happy to be here I get to
spend time with other women from the
village it's fun but it's also a bit
daunting to learn at our age we
grandmother's help each other during
class so it's not that scary the
grandmothers school set up by a charity
has 28 students they practice the
alphabet in Marathi the local language
sheetal Morey has been teaching here
since the school opened last summer the
goal is to teach the grandmothers to
read and write simple sentences
Patrice's progress has been slow many of
the grandmothers are quite old they
don't have a good memory so they forget
things easily that means we need to
constantly repeat and go over the same
things in class lessons are over in two
hours most of the grandmothers here were
married off as young girls and had no
chance at an education many grew up with
grinding poverty back at home Yashoda
remembers even going hungry on some days
Yeshua's family is religious a Hindu
shrine occupies a central place in a
home her husband Prabhakar is proud that
his wife is taking such a brave step the
grandmothers school will help our
village progress it will make the older
women more aware and more confident the
school is already given Yashoda a sense
of dignity over something as simple as
leaving the coat salman us a yeah lemme
earlier i should just put my [ __ ] print
on bank documents but now i can sign my
own name imagine that it feels really
good the next time i go to the bank the
officials there will be so impressed in
the ending yeah shoulders granddaughters
who are back from school help her with
her homework giving her a break from
household chores save my grandmother
works a lot she cooks she makes tea she
cleans she finds no time to learn her
granddaughter's however ensure Yashoda
continues to make progress even when
school's over
[Music]